[Music]  pirates had infected disease for  generations wife Alcala named mo and  then there was this boy  just Farkle  Paul Heyman  he took everything from me  and  great  [Applause]  her story my Spanish captain with son to  be killed thousands of men live another  Bengal pirates  I read all snus when you doing something  in Spanish  becoming to you jack  there's no [ __ ] the crew  the past yeah - I'm so sorry we're still  talking the stores like  find spyro for me  from this moment on we are the ally  considerin way all next time to decide  where most math  stop thank you  [Music]  I'm going to the trouble horrible  waggling  you pay for what you did to me  I'm not sure if I'm looking for jacket  I'm going to swim for it Karina stop  that no no no no this has gone far  enough  no it head off I saw her ankles  you'da seen a lot more as you kept the  hike holeshot  you